(uplifting music)
(chanting)
- I want my daughter and
the rest of the Monarchs
to grow up in a world that
sees them and affirms them
and that gives them the
space to be able to show up
as their full selves to
celebrate who they are
as young girls of color.
(upbeat music)
My name is Anayvette Martinez,
and I am one of the co-founders
of the Radical Monarchs.
- And my name is Lupita Martinez,
and I'm a Radical Monarch.
- [Narrator] The Radical Monarchs
is a progressive scouting
troop for young girls of color.
The troop's mission is
to create opportunities
for the girls to form a fierce sisterhood,
celebrate their identities
and contribute radically
to their communities.
- I launched the Radical
Monarchs in December of 2014
because when Lupita was in fourth grade
she wanted to join a local scouting troop.
I felt like the traditional scouting group
wouldn't really speak to her experience
as a young girl of color and as a girl
that's been raised with
really radical politics.
And, so, I had this idea
of what would it look like
to start a different kind of troop
where girls could earn badges,
but that the badges they earned
were based on social
justice issues and topics.
(gentle music)
- [Narrator] The Monarchs
earn badges for each unit
that they cover, and each
badge has an activity
out in the community, like
participating in marches,
meeting with legislators
and talking with activists
who came before them.
- Some of the badges that
we've earned are Radical Roots,
Radical Bodies and then
our newest one today,
which was Radical Media.
For the Radical Healing badge,
we learned about
different ways of healing,
healing with plants, healing with herbs.
And then, for the Black
Lives Matter badge,
we went to the Martin Luther King march.
(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] The Radical
Monarchs recently started
their second troop and hope to expand
to reach even more girls.
- My vision and dream for the Monarchs
is that we have troops and chapters
wherever we're needed and wanted.
As it is right now, we
get requests constantly
from all over the country,
all over the world even.
Especially in today's climate,
I think that is needed now more than ever.